let's say a writer decides they would
like to write a romantic comedy and it's
for not just the market but for their
own catharsis or need to tell stories so
what should they know before they even
put one word down on the page about
writing romantic comedies I think in
writing romantic comedies one of the
most important things to remember is
that it's a three part trip now not
necessarily three acts but there are
three things that need to happen this is
the this is the genre boy meets girl boy
loses girl boy gets girl back yeah gotta
have all that now or it can be you know
girl meets boy girl loses boy girl meets
girl boy meets whatever but you need to
have that that initial spark that we see
them feeling for each other and we go
yeah there's something there even if
it's they're both fighting it right yeah
that you're not my type oh no I never go
with someone like you but you know oh
yeah sparks are flying and then there is
that split and it looks like it's over
and then we spend quite some time
watching one of them at least try to
figure out how to get the other person
back so it's that struggle if you will
to regain or to claim what you saw in
that first part of the film and then the
third part is the rien gauging and
seeing how that works now in romantic
dramas the third part might not end well
it might be a tragedy and they don't get
together but even then you want to feel
that you know what they have lost
now in a romantic comedy we want them to
get back together this echoes
interestingly enough the myth of Orpheus
and or a DJ that three parts of girl
meets boy girl loses boy girl gets boy
back is an echo of the ancient Greek
myth about
Orpheus and or a DJ they're madly in
love it's their wedding day and she goes
off to pick some flowers and gets bitten
by a poisonous snake dies goes to Hades
Orpheus who was the first rock star he
was a musician and they said he was so
good and so magnetic and charismatic
that he he'd be walking down the lane
playing music and the trees would uproot
themselves and the rocks would grow legs
to follow after him because his music
was so compelling so he loses his wife
his beloved is dead and gone he stops
playing he stops singing and the world
around him starts to go gray to lose its
colour because of lost love so you've
had the first part they're together
they're happy they're ecstatic then the
separation and in this instance of the
myth it's very dark and the whole world
suffers because of their loss in a
romantic comedy it usually isn't that
big of an effect but a lot of people do
suffer when somebody breaks up you know
whether it's the friend who goes I'm so
tired of hearing the same story please
go out with me tonight and meet some
more people or the parents who are
saying oh dear you'll find more there's
more fish in the sea no I don't want
fish I want him so that separation then
reflects that myth and in the mythic
story
Orpheus says I got to get her back and
the goddess of love Aphrodite says hang
on here just a minute she goes and talks
to Hades the king of the underworld and
they have a little thing together and
she's oh come on the kids are in love
things aren't going well up there let
them get back together and Hades says
okay fine but he can't talk to her and
he can't look at her but if he can get
her to follow him up back into the upper
world then yeah okay she can be alive
again and the stories vary
and it spawned a number of wonderful
operas and and movies he goes into the
underworld he finds his love so romantic
comedy right you search out the beloved
you're willing to try anything and but
they're often strings attached and
that's where they can get so fun in that
that part - of a romantic comedy what
are the barriers what are the hoops you
have to go through what are the rings of
fire to get back that person that you
love right
well Orpheus gets down to the underworld
and he sees her a DJ he starts playing
and he spots it from a distance because
he's not supposed to look at everything
so he starts walking back up and playing
and singing and she hears him and starts
to follow but and here's where you also
find a great echo for your romantic
comedy scripts on the way up she keeps
saying to him Orpheus is it you won't
you look at me what is it tell me
something tell me it's you tell me you
love me but he can't he can't or it'll
ruin everything now in some of the
stories he just can't resist and his
heart is breaking so he turns around and
looks at her and holds out his hand and
even though he's made it over the
threshold of the underworld she hasn't
and she gets zapped back down and
they're separated forever now that's a
tragedy but in a romantic comedy we're
gonna do the other version and then that
version
Aphrodite goes back to Hades and she
says Oh seriously come on I mean they
were that close and the kids are in love
and you know what love does don't you
and so Hades goes yeah okay fine okay
fine
taker so Orpheus and Aditya get reunited
so we have that tragedy as the format
the mythic pattern for romantic comedies
you